the government's newest monthly
employment report comes out this morning
joblessness as you know has soared since
the coronavirus pandemic began but
wall street even despite yesterday's
more than 800 point slide in the dow
is booming google amazon and apple are
all worth more than a trillion dollars
mark straussman looks at the disconnect
between investors
and hard hit workers wow it's ridiculous
that we have to
stand in line like this covet america
has forced the jobless
to redefine success forget the dream job
find a paycheck i had the dream job and
because of covet i lost it eric
beltran's a beer expert
and sure lots of 26 year olds believe
they are
but he worked as a brewer beltran was
furloughed in mid-march
laid off in late may his unemployment
benefits
abruptly stopped he's gone four weeks
without
one nickel in income at this point it is
just trying to find a uh
trying to find a safe job a paycheck
yeah how stressful is it
i don't get that interview i don't get
the job i don't get
unemployment it just weighs on me more
and more
since mid-march in covet america more
than 59 million people have filed
unemployment claims in that same time
the new york stock exchange has grown
more than
41 percent driven largely by tech stocks
it's
created big winners and big losers
mark zandy chief economist at moody's
analytics
credits record low interest rates for
rocketing stock prices
but half of americans own no stocks
about a fifth of americans are
working less and getting paid less than
they did before the pandemic so that's
the real result of the pandemic the
stock market is
just completely disconnected from that
wall street
means nothing to the main street where
eric beltran
still looks for work is the economy
doing any better
for you for me no absolutely not it's
great that
the apple and tesla are flying high
doesn't really change the fact that
you know i have to move in with parents
beltran really should qualify for
unemployment he's trying to work through
a bureaucratic issue with the state of
georgia
he went from making four thousand
dollars a month in benefits
to zero and remember this is a guy who
describes himself as relentlessly
optimistic
but he admits gail it's starting to get
to him
yeah and who can blame him but someone's
watching him right now
they're looking for somebody who's
relentlessly optimistic oh somebody
reaches out to him because of that story
thank you very much mark